le tourisme vert une tendance de fond
comment s'explique
comment le secteur touristique
s'adapte-t-il pour accueillir ces
nouveaux voyageurs j'en ai vraiment qui
spécifiquement m'appelle et me disent je
ne voyage que dans un établissement et
co-responsable les modes d'hébergement
écho touristiques se multiplient
je pense que c'est ce qui nous attire un
peu le côté nature le côté oui affirmé
écologie
les activités suivent la même évolution
état des lieux dans la région
le chant des oiseaux au cœur de la forêt
nous sommes aux portes du parc naturel
régional du Perche dans l'un des 56
camping labellisés par le groupe
Utopia ici tout est conçu autour de la
nature
quasi à la belle étoile ça c'est plutôt
chouette en fait on a des habitats qui
se font bien dans le dans
l'environnement et
rémunesthétique assez sympa dans ses
campings
chose qu'on peut des fois ne pas
retrouver dans des campings un peu plus
classiques et nous on était des habitués
du camping sauvage avant et c'est vrai
qu'ici on retrouve un peu cette idée de
de camping sauvage de nature et c'est ce
qui nous plaît
[Musique]
les 77 hébergements démontables sont
répartis sur près de 13 hectares une
pièce d'eau une piscine des sauna
agrémente l'endroit on est sur un
concept nature c'est à dire que chez
Utopia vous avez plusieurs types
d'hébergement des hébergements légers en
toile ou des hébergements un peu plus
durs essentiellement en bois qui sont
équipés d'un poêle à bois pour avoir
chaud et pour être confortable et c'est
surtout l'environnement qui est
important l'environnement c'est la
nature on cherche essentiellement une
reconnexion donc à la nature
à 1h30 de Paris le site offre un réel
dépaysement aux familles citadines
clientèle privilégié des lieux non tu as
fait la douche une parenthèse bienvenue
pour un week-end ou une semaine de
vacances
peu d'espaces verts assez peu
d'occasions de partir en week-end et du
coup c'est vrai que l'été enfin les
vacances de façon générale quand on part
avec les enfants on privilégie quand
même des vacances en nature et puis ils
auront bien l'âge de faire des visites
culturelles dans d'autres capitales mais
là on a ce qui les rend heureux c'est la
nature nous on trouve ça très bien ça
développe l'imagination pas d'écran rien
et c'est un très bon très bon équilibre
parents-enfant quoi parce que nous ça
nous fait du bien aussi
toutes les activités sont gratuites
elles sont là encore tournées vers
l'environnement apiculture permaculture
ateliers de vannerie autant d'animations
qui participent à l'éveil des petits
comme des grands
c'est vraiment un plus pour le
déroulement du séjour c'est un vrai
plaisir c'est c'est des activités
intelligentes c'est vraiment enchanté de
ce type d'expérience et moi ça me donne
l'occasion aussi de faire de la vannerie
j'en avais jamais trouvé donc c'est
super
chaque année la fréquentation de ces
campings progresse de plus de 20%
[Musique]
changement de lieu changement d'ambiance
voici une tiny house micro maison mobile
déposée au cœur même d'un élevage caprin
peut-être que si on les appelle elles
vont venir
touristo landaise a craqué pour la ferme
d'Alexandra
dans un cadre privilégié sa tiny house
dispose de tout le confort nécessaire
le lit est à environ un mètre de hauteur
il surplombe tout le paysage et tout est
là
des toilettes sèches une douche
un retour à la nature essentiel pour
Dorine une forme d'interaction bénéfique
pour Alexandra c'est un échange quelque
part c'est à la fois ouvrir notre ferme
à des personnes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité au quotidien de d'être au
cœur de la campagne et puis pour nous
éleveur ou agriculteurs c'est aussi la
joie d'accueillir du monde sur sur notre
ferme de faire partager notre quotidien
et de leur montrer le travail le fruit
de notre travail nos produits
[Musique]
et découverte de la fabrication des
fromages
[Musique]
je les prends et je les laisse une
journée de plus avant de les retourner à
nouveau
j'ai visité une fois une fabrique de
fromage en Hollande pour les gros
fromages mais jamais pour du fromage de
chèvre je n'ai jamais vu ça avant un art
de vivre à la française qui séduit
d'autant plus quand ces visages sont
multiples
car voici l'hébergement naturel par
excellence le gîte
troglodytique
il ne nécessite aucune construction
seulement quelques aménagements tendance
écolo naturellement
pour le confort déjà on a mis un
plancher chauffant donc avec une pompe à
chaleur air eau ensuite on a mis une VMC
double flux qui permet de limiter
considérablement l'humidité parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que voilà on est dans
la roche même si c'est quelque chose de
très très isolé il faut quand même faire
en sorte que l'humidité s'en aille et
puis après c'est des petits gestes enfin
des petites choses comme du lin sur les
lits des contenants réutilisables des
produits et collabellisés et puis bien
sûr des produits bio et de saison le
succès est indéniable 96% de réservation
d'avril à octobre signe révélateur d'une
évolution des mentalités j'en ai
vraiment qui spécifiquement m'appelle et
me disent je ne voyage que dans un
établissement éco-responsable donc ça ça
existe c'est une nouvelle forme de de
touristes
et c'est assez récent
les 2022 là je crois que c'est avancé
on s'approche de la fin de fermentation
Julie et Nicolas ne se contentent pas de
louer leur troglo à travers la
viticulture ils font découvrir aux
voyageurs ce patrimoine
architecturaliste torique du Val de
Loire ces caves qui dissimulent parfois
d'étonnantes surprises là on est à peu
près 8 10 mètres de rochers quoi et puis
donc les arbres qui sont sur le coteau
et avec quelques racines qui arrivent à
s'infiltrer dans les failles et on sait
que les racines ont un pouvoir de
pénétration incroyable et elles écartent
même un petit peu les failles elles
viennent chercher l'humidité dans la
cave
[Musique]
tout aussi intimiste tout aussi typique
de la région un autre type de logement
insolites côtoient les bords de Loire la
toux cabanais attention messieurs dames
là les morceaux de bois sont glissants
Isabelle et Alain vont passer la nuit
sur l'eau bercé par les mouvements du
fleuve
vous avez une une douche une douche
solaire dont le
la bourriche est sur le toit qui chauffe
au soleil toute la toute la journée
l'endroit est spartiate mais se font
parfaitement dans cet espace ligérien au
cœur d'une nature
omniprésente
profiter du lever de soleil de demain
matin avec enfin j'espère le soleil et
puis les oiseaux au réveil aussi c'est
pareil c'est quand toute la faune se met
en activité
dès les premières lueurs du jour et ben
tout se remet en vie c'est ça qui est
beau sur la loi moi je viens surtout
pour les couleurs les couleurs de la
nature les couleurs sur l'eau le soleil
si normalement ça devrait être bien
le soleil n'est pas au rendez-vous mais
qu'importe
[Musique]
on aperçoit vous voyez les traces que
les castors ont grignoter le bas des
arbres là on voit c'est c'est tout
récent parce qu'il y a quelques jours ça
y était pas donc ils ont commencé à
attaquer donc pour nous ça nous rassure
parce que on sait qu'ils sont là
ces amoureux de la nature profitent et
découvrent le biotope ligérien
on adore
au retour en forêt pour une ultime
habitation et qu'autouristique les
fameuses cabanes dans les arbres
seulement particularités ici c'est
LOCATION s'adresse à un public haut de
gamme
urbain avide de déconnexion
j'adore la chambre j'adore la position
hauteur là
c'est assez spectaculaire la
construction l'architecture moderne
chacun des 18 lots d'isolés a été décoré
par un artiste différent l'art fait
d'ailleurs partie du concept à 4 mètres
de haut un spa est installé sur chaque
terrasse ouverte vers le ciel
la cabane version luxe là c'est un peu
moins écolo mais ça doit être quand même
très très agréable
le début
le fait qu'il y ait pas de wifi c'est
absolument parfait parce qu'on est
malheureusement tous très tenté
dès qu'elle wifi et donc c'est la
décompression déconnexion forcée on
débranche tout et on se laisse porter
par la nature
compter 4 à 500 euros la nuit suivant
les prestations avec une philosophie
tournée entièrement vers le bien-être
je propose à mes clients c'est de
laisser la forêt rentrer en eux et de
développer des sens plus intuitif et
plus intérieur comme
tout ce qu'on peut ressentir qu'on
appelle l'intérioception qui est quand
on prend un joli exemple quand on est
amoureux et qu'on a des guilis dans le
ventre
les clients peuvent ici bénéficier de
massages ou de séances de silvothérapie
l'idée mieux communier avec la nature à
l'image par exemple des relations entre
les chaînes et les charmes ils font des
branches et beaucoup de feuilles pour se
préserver un petit peu de la chaleur et
ils sont aidés par les chaînes qui du
coup passent au dessus les grands arbres
solaires et qui leur renvoient l'été
quand il transpire de l'humidité et du
coup il y a une belle collaboration
entre les deux
insolite patrimoniaux les modes
d'hébergement écotouristiques se sont
donc diversifiés pour répondre à la
demande mais quelle est la véritable
implication de ces voyageurs
cette tendance écolo c'est bien gentille
de dire aux gens il faut sauver la
planète agir pour le climat mais si on
sait pas de quoi on parle et qu'on
connaît pas le milieu forestier et qu'on
connaît même pas comment fonctionne un
arbre enfin on comprend rien finalement
donc on n'a pas envie d'agir donc moi
tout simplement je les amène à
comprendre la force du vivant et puis
d'avoir envie de revenir tout simplement
dans cet environnement et du coup
d'avoir envie de d'agir pour le sauver
reste qu'il demeure aujourd'hui
difficile de quantifier l'ampleur et
l'impact écologique d'un phénomène
encore très récent